you had dinner with the president last
night there was a big picture photo
picture with the thumbs up very
celebratory what were you all
celebrating just the accomplishments
we've had two heretofore
and then the rest of the agenda that
we're working on we're working on
infrastructure work on some healthcare
bills we're working on lots of different
bills with respect to Workforce
Development Career and Technical
Education and we were celebrating the
agenda we've passed and the agenda we
have yet to pass this this this session
in this spring because you know when I
look at that picture Mr Speaker I have
to say I don't see anybody that looks
like me in terms of color or gender and
you were one of the main people that
said you want to do more for the
Republican Party to expand you wanted to
expand the base some say this president
really doesn't want to expand the base
so when I look at that picture I have to
say I don't feel very soon yeah I feel
very excluded why I don't like the fact
that you feel that way and we need more
minorities more women in our party and
I've been focusing on that kind of
recruitment the the person who I'm a
mentor to literally technically I became
her mentor as Mia love she's somebody I
recruited in the primary to come to
Congress there are a lot of candidates
like Mia that were recruiting all around
the country because I do believe that
and that's something I'm gonna keep
working on that's something I'm not
going away from from from life I'm gonna
keep being involved in focusing on
inclusive aspirational politics I'm
gonna keep fighting for the things I
believe and that's among the things I
want to do I'm gonna spend a lot of time
with my friend Bob Woodson on poverty
initiatives those are things I care a
great deal about that frankly I have
been not able to spend time on because
of a pretty busy day job